تتواصل الحرب المستعره الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه وكذلك المحاصيل الزراعيه
والاراضي الزراعيه جزء من هذه الحرب التي
يتم فيها تدمير هذه الاراضي من قبل قوات
الاحتلال خاصه في الاجزاء الشرقيه منها
وهناك اعداد كبيره ومساحات كبيره من اراضي
المواطنين تم تجريفها وتدميرها من قبل
قوات الاحتلال يعني لو تطلعنا على اليه
العمل وحجم العمل هنا خاصه مع استمرار
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وتعملون
في هذا الخطر والخوف الشديد اليوم احنا في
ظل الحرب والماساه اللي احنا بنمر فيها
اللي ان مساحات الزراعيه اللي في رفح
مساحات ضئيله جدا ولا تكفي احتياجات
السكان زي ما انت شايف يعني هي البطاطا
لتر السولار كلفنا حوالي 30 شيكل يعني كل
يوم انا بدي 2 2500 شيكل ب سولار فان جبرت
جبار هذ بد كمان 20 يوم لما يعني تخ شجت
جبار على الخلع لانه احنا في منطقه خانون
منطقه
مستهدفه قله المحاصيل الزراعيه الموجوده
في السوق الى ماذا يعود يعود الى الحصار
اللي الحصار اللي على
غزه المناطق المهجوره في بيت
لاهيه غزه انسرات كل هذه مناطق زراعيه كل
هذه راحت يعني منطقه بيت لاهيه تشكل 60%
من المحصلات الزراعيه وبيت حنون كلها راحت
اليوم كيلو البصل عندك ب 30 شيكل كيلو
الليمون عندك ب 12 شيكل كيلو باذنجان عندك
10 شيكل الاسعار خياليه واليوم النازحين
الاج الله ربنا يكون في عونهم الله
النازحين اجوا من الشمال والي اجوا من
الوسطى اللي جايب له معه شويه مصاري له
120 يوم لو كل يوم بصرف له 100 شيكل ما ظل
معه مصاري الناس صارت كلها الحين عايشه
على المعلبات اغلبيه الناس بتطلع الخضره
ما بتقدر تشتريها المحاصيل الموجوده في
السوق ايش المحاصيل الموجوده ما ضلش شي
يعني مدر ل البطاطا ومافيش اصلا مش مكفيه
للسوق اصلا اليومي هنا
يكافحون في كل شيء من اجل شيء واحد وهو
البقاء على الحياه في ظل سماء ملبده بسحب
الموت اسماعيل ابو
عمر قناه الجزيره خان يونس